welcome to other technology Tuesday
today I'm answering a question for my
YouTube viewers love you guys
mm Jago who wrote in wanting to know how
to get access to your Evernote notes
when you're offline on mobile I'm
looking for a note app that will sync
this seems perfect that my data plan
isn't always on I pay per minute so only
go online when I need to check mail and
so on if I create a new note on the
phone does that mean I will have to go
online every time I want to view it
unless I mark it as offline and make it
non syncing note that seems silly to me
surely the note should be on the phone
whether online or not but if the note
has been edited elsewhere then that
version will only come to the phone when
online or synced which makes sense if I
have to go online every time I open
Evernote then it seems a bit pointless I
would appreciate some clarity from
someone familiar with everyone's
functionality before installing and
trying it for myself
Thanks so yes you're correct if you
create a note in your Evernote offline
it will always be there until you sync
it online I'll show you how I use it on
my phone so first thing I'm going to do
is turn off my Wi-Fi so I have no
connection to the internet then I'm
gonna load my Evernote and I'm gonna
create a new note
I'll put test and it's in this put it in
a folder that does not sync myself
tracking folder does not sync offline
mode and this is a test test and let's
put a picture
save and done so what's gonna happen now
is you'll see it here it'll be always
loaded on your local so be on your phone
and they'll have this little symbol here
that means it needs to upload and I can
always load it again and I'm still
offline mode so I can always go and look
at it edit it but if I make any changes
off my computer then that won't be
edited until it sinks again properly so
I hope that I answered your question
those are you watching you like the
video you want to see more you can
subscribe to the channel and if you have
other Evernote questions or Technology
questions let me know in the comments
below I'll try to answer them for you
thank you and keep believing don't
forget to check out my newsletter link
below
hi I'm Jason G - see Carazo online calm
and I want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and it's only newsletter I prioritize
and look forward to period